[Music]
all right so uh my name is Dave stanky
I'm part of the developer relations team
here at Google and with me is
Christopher Sanson he's the product
manager for cloud built they'll be up a
little later and that character up in
the top right that's Billy the Builder
be and she'll be helping us out later on
so we're shifting left what does that
mean it means to incorporate critical
processes early in the software
development cycle what does that mean
well we can usually model a software
development process as a left-to-right
flow where we go from code through some
transformations see if it's any good
ship it and then operate monitor as its
as its live and we model this as a
left-to-right flow shifting left means
moving this important steps of
validation and quality control earlier
in the process closer to the left of
course software development doesn't
happen in a single stream we usually
have lots of these flows and in a
traditional process every developer or
team progresses independently they're
focused on writing more and more code
until at the last minute everything
collides and all at once
all of these bits are meeting for the
first time and we're hoping for a quick
thumbs up let's ship it but when you
have a whole bunch of code it's
strangers to each other you shove them
all on a room at once it might not get
along and so it's more likely that we're
gonna have merge conflicts and have
terrible security holes we're gonna have
incompatibilities between some systems
and this is why in a traditional
waterfall style development process you
often have huge lengthy merge times you
often have long lead times and you often
have terrible weeks before and after a
major release so we shift left we move
processes earlier to get earlier
feedback on small checks all along the
way so if you take two small pieces and
you validate each of them independently
and then when they combine the only
thing we actually have to test it then
is what
there is what arises between the
connections between them
so what are we shifting left well you
can shift left lots of things first off
you can shift your merges left and this
is continuous integration in the
original meaning that instead of having
long-lived branches that hang out on a
developer's machine for a long time
we're gonna merge at least once a day
preferably more often and each one of
those merges is then small relatively
pain-free and we don't have the merge
that everyone dreads can also shift left
on security so a lot of times
traditionally we put together a big
software release and then just before we
ship we go to the security people more
like it's good right give us a thumbs up
and they say slow down well we can do a
lot better but we do security of our
validation earlier and oftener so within
code you can do things like automated
fuzz testing to make sure that your code
is actually has some protection you can
test individual components look at open
source packages you might be using using
vulnerability analysis and generally
have affirmation that your code is
pretty secure
all along the way and at the end you're
only validating again that very outer
perimeter of the code and then you can
shift left on testing and this is what
we're gonna really dig into testing
early and often and why do we want to
test early to catch bugs early I bet a
lot of folks here are familiar with the
research that's been done by NST and IBM
talking about how finding a bug in
development costs way less time and
energy than finding one in production
the numbers I've heard or anywhere from
6 X to 30 X to a hundred X but certainly
you'd rather catch the bug early why why
is it so much cheaper well I think
there's a couple reasons one if you
catch it early it hasn't had time to
have downstream effects the other system
components aren't aware of that bug
they're not working around that bug as
they sometimes do and two if you catch a
bug while developers still working on
that process it's still in their mind
they're still in that flow and so they
don't have to rehydrate and reconstruct
what was I thinking when I wrote that
code
with the bug in it so for these reasons
it's really great to fix our bugs early
and be testing early now oh and one
quick bit of science here from the state
of DevOps report and actually I believe
there's a card on everyone if your seats
encouraging you to participate double
report does analysis finding out what
practices are done by teams that have
the most software quality and they find
that continuous testing predicts
continuous delivery which predicts
delivery performance how often we ship
and how fast we get from code to live
and availability how often or how much
of the time our services are available
alright so let's look at testing and how
we can shift left on it first of all
some definitions so we often talk about
testing as they testing hierarchy start
at the bottom with unit tests and unit
tests of course are the foundation unit
tests are where we test small
functionality of our code kind of within
the frameworks of our code and and
honestly these are a mostly solved
problem maybe but most modern frameworks
have unit testing built in it tenderly
can be run pretty quickly as part of
your build and CI process integration
testing is when we test multiple
components together and when we make
sure that when these things are actually
running like in production that when
they work together they don't all of a
sudden fall apart you just want to work
that one worked but the application
doesn't work until you have both of them
and on top that we have end-to-end
testing which means usually running a
multi-step process against a composed
application it's kind of a fuzzy line
between Integris and integration testing
and end-to-end testing and the terms are
sometimes used interchangeably now this
diagram might look like at all
intimidating icy Mountain but we're
going to show you that it's not that
hard to scale to the pinnacle of testing
today's focus is on integration testing
but everything we're looking at can be
used for été testing as well so our
goals for integration testing we want
high fidelity high isolation high
scalability appropriate ephemerality and
we always like speed and low cost we're
not going to get all the way but these
are an aspiration to shoot for I'm going
to show you some ways that we can get
close so first of all Fidel
now when we do integration testing we
start by creating a system under test
that's the environment that we're going
to test against we're not going to test
against prod right and so we create a
simulation effectively and our goal here
is fidelity how similar is that system
under test to the production system the
closer we get the more assured we are
that we're gonna have we're gonna have
tested that reflect what reality is
going to be like what our users are
going to experience and we're generally
not gonna be able to create a full
production environment for each test
although will challenge that later on so
we're gonna run against the scaled-down
version of that full ecosystem and aim
to make it as predictive as possible
isolation this means that each test is
running completely separate from the
others they're not going to stomp on
each other to compete for processes CPU
memory disk space whatever and they also
don't share connect to the same external
resources if you have a shared database
or a prod a P I you know even if it's
read-only it's entirely possible for a
runaway read to block everyone else from
using it isolation also has to do with
security so we want to configure all of
the resources we use within tests to not
have public visibility the last thing we
want is for someone to corrupt our tests
or somehow give us bad data that then
sneaks into prod somehow or run a
Bitcoin miner on our protected testing
infrastructure and then scalability of
course we want big how many tests can we
run at a time ideally every developer
can kick off all of their tests at the
same time we don't want developers
waiting while their tests are queued up
behind their colleagues remember that
flow we discussed keep the developers
going and this means we want to be able
to scale the test infrastructure
elastically and paralyze all of our
tests so that of course is a great fit
for cloud infrastructure and then
ephemerality which means how long does
that test infrastructure hang around
after we're done doing our tests ideally
it lasts just until the test is over and
then it's gone right we don't want to
pay for it and then we optimize the
nature of the test but the thing is if
the test gets torn down immediately that
we don't have access to go debug what
happens inside that test environment
now of course best practices you should
not be SSA Qing into your fraud machines
but for a test machine you can learn a
lot from a failed test by going in and
saying well what's going on what process
is there what what actual data got
written into that file oh it's not what
I expected
so the best ephemerality means that the
test that the system lasts exactly as
long as I need it and not any longer
and of course speed is good we like fast
this is important both so that we can
keep our developers productive and also
so we can increase our mean time to
deploy decrease your other fast is
better than slow and finally
affordability developer time is
expensive and generally it's a good use
of money to give infrastructure to
developers for their tests but it's
always gonna be a trade-off and you
certainly don't want to pay more for
your testing than it's worth for the
sake of your production environments all
right now I'm going to kick off a quick
demo can we switch to the air we go all
right so what I'm gonna do here is I'm
going to start off a series of four
tests I'm not gonna explain them just
yet I'm just gonna get them going but
I'm in my editor here and I'm running
this as a g-cloud submit command of
course you can also run this from a
trigger as well so we'll kick that off
and we will head to our UI and we'll be
able to sir this is the cloud console
and we're gonna look at the progress and
we're just getting started on it and
back to slide please and now Christopher
is going to come up talk to us a little
about what testing is really like and
how close we get to those goals
everyone so as Dave mentioned my name is
Christopher a product manager at Google
working on cloud build which gives you a
bit of a hint of what I might be talking
about but before we get into it you know
one thing we hear from customers all the
time is you know you come to an event
like this you read blogs
read up on the best practices and it's
really inspiring you know you hear about
things like shift left things like
DevOps sree infrastructure is code but
when we get to talk to customers and
sort of back in reality is that look
this is this is great you know but this
is kind of like flying cars you know
like we get it but it's so far from
where we are today and sort of our day
to day reality is like we need help both
with tooling and operations and
processes to help us get to where we
want to be so I want to take a quick
minute to sort of look at sort of sub
test patterns and test strategies that
we see in the real world and sort of
kind of why those may be sort of what's
happening when things like shift left I
think are are sort of reasonably
accepted as sort of best practices so I
think the first test that anyone kind of
ever runs is the build itself right
every application starts with you know
compiling code running a build and you
kind of iterate and you sort of test
your code and you hack on and you debug
and then eventually finally the build is
green right and so that's I think often
you know as far as a lot of different
sort of applications ever go right if
the build is green my app is breathing
right but obviously in modern
architectures with things like micro
services and external dependencies just
because your build is green really gives
you no indication that your ultimate
application is going to run correctly
right there's a lot of external
dependencies that can change out from
underneath you while you're working
other api's can shift and so you really
need to actually test and validate that
the way that your application works
isn't just completed of itself but
actually in the way that it talks to
other services so the next thing we see
a lot of people do is sort of okay the
build is green and they start adding
quality gates so these are sort of
static analysis tools either commercial
like code Cove or Coverity as well as
open source things like JSA and jslint
things like that and qual dates are
really great they are very fast they're
very cheap and they give you a really
good indication of sort of code quality
right they can do everything from
validating against your style guide
linting giving you a sense of how much
code coverage you have the challenge
though is like for anyone that's looked
ahead if you look at sort of the unit
test that we wrote that you to test
isn't really going to help you very much
right all it's really going to
you is just get your code coverage up to
80% so you can be allowed to like merge
your commits so what we find is like you
know quality gates are really helpful
and really powerful for sort of
indicating that your code is probably
going to work but it doesn't actually do
anything to verify that your code will
work right so our T's sort of had
quality gates this is sort of my
personal favorite test strategy and when
they've often employed I like to call
Humpty Dumpty tests this is where you
don't actually write any tests till
after the failure occurs something will
go down in pride you'll have an outage
your users will sort of talk to you and
say hey this is this is down you figure
out the route calls you submit a quick
fix and then you go back and write test
coverage now obviously this is a big
reality of software development you're
not going to catch everything but I
think it's sort of ease you don't really
want your users to be your QA right you
want to test and capture these things
before they reach users by the way I
want to give a shout out to our
illustrator Tracy this is maybe my
favorite illustration that I've ever had
at a talk I've given we sort of it were
like well the idea is it's sort of like
it's Humpty Dumpty it breaks and this is
what she came up with so shout out to
Tracy and the last thing is you know the
kind of classic almost cliched at this
point it's sort of well it worked on my
machine so we ran kind of a survey on
Twitter we asked people so from people
microservice architectures where's
where's the first point in time that you
actually test your app versus the other
services it interacts with and this
number was actually a lot higher than we
thought so so 43% of developers were
actually testing it in their local
machine before pushing to Prague so this
is actually encouraging but this often
leads to the kind of it worked on my
machine the sort of classic failure mode
where you throw it over the wall to the
deployment or ops team and then there's
this back-and-forth of blame game of
like well it worked for me but it's not
working for me
etc this happens because you know there
are different versions there's different
OS is there's different file path
dependencies just because you run a test
locally doesn't really give you a ton of
confidence that it's going to run either
in your CI system or in production so
you know
why why are these some of the patterns
that we see and I don't I don't think
we're not try to present these as anti
patterns right like if something goes
down you should write a test to cover it
for the next time you should do quality
gates you should be testing locally but
I think what we found is that when it
gets to things like integration testing
it's really it's just not that easy
right it's not that easy to do there's a
lot of friction to the some of the
primary reasons I think just as a
developer myself is that you know the
last thing you want to do as developers
to sort of lose float:right is to get
out of the context and have to wait for
a long build and if you are using a
hosted CI service that you know you
paper concurrency or if you're self
hosting your infrastructure and you're
responsible for scaling it up and down
you know can lead to long build times
long queue times so as a developer you
kind of you find your own workarounds
right you test things locally you write
fewer tests you test later on in the
process so this is where sort of some of
the tule can really kind of empower
developers to lower the bar of entry for
sort of testing things earlier on in the
process and the other aspect is just
kind of environment management so it's
it's simply just somewhat difficult
often in different situations to
provision infrastructure manage that
infrastructure spin up databases and
spin them down things like that so which
leads us to sort of cloud build so cloud
build if you've been the other talks you
may have heard of if your GP cluster you
need to be using currently if you're
familiar with it cloud build is a hosted
CI CD service on GCP for building
testing and deploying applications it's
generally available it launched about
two years ago originally called
container builder last year and next we
announced it as cloud bill does it
covered a broader spectrum of CI CD use
cases and I think one of the biggest
things that we hear people really like
about it is that it's serverless for
whatever that word may mean to you it's
fully managed infrastructure and you pay
for what you use so you pay for a build
minute so if you have a huge CI
infrastructure that's idle most of the
time you don't really have to worry
about that and the last thing is what
are the announcements this week is cloud
build is adding support for hybrid and
multi-cloud workloads so it's currently
an alpha it's a new feature called
custom workers but it's going to let you
use cloud build with a V PC to connect
to your on-prem private networks so if
you have a self hosted repository or
you're deploying to a runtime like GK on
to print on Prem cloud builds gonna be
able to work we've managed
infrastructure with sort of services and
resources behind your firewall so let's
take a look real quick so how cloud
build works there's a build config file
that's in yellow of course and in that
you sort of define what you want cloud
build to do for you so you define a
series of build steps and then that
could figure you can do things like
define your dependency graph environment
variables it integrates with kms so you
can do secret management as well as sort
of the artifacts that you want to build
so what this looks like your pipeline is
you have often source code in your
repository you can set up automated
build triggers so that when you commit
to your repo based on branch or tag or
pull requests it'll kick off a cloud
build and in that build you'll run a
series of build steps and so build steps
are like Jenkins stages or github
actions or you know any sort of CI
systems concept of jobs or tasks I mean
each build step is a container in the
cloud build world so anything that could
be containerized can be run as a build
step and at the end of your build you
know there's some outputs there's a
status usually pass/fail any artifacts
that were created and then any
deployments that were made if you're
using it for continuous delivery so what
are some common build steps we have a
whole bunch of supported builder images
out-of-the-box
things like docker bill may even build
there's a g-cloud one so any command
with the cloud SDK you can run locally
you can run in a hosted cloud
environment with cloud build and the
last one is sort of you could bring your
own container so as I mentioned we have
a bunch of predefined ones for the most
popular tooling but if you have custom
tooling custom versions you want to use
any sort of arbitrary scripts you run on
one if you could containerize that then
Cloud Ville can execute it for you in a
hosted environment so if you start to
kind of think about the possibilities
there sort of what that means is like
people are offered like well what like
is cloud bill just for building things
and the answers will sort of yes but it
could do a lot more it could be used for
sort of anything that can run inside of
the container so in the context of
integration testing which Dave is going
to show us a little bit more tactically
how this works in practice you can use
some of the common tools right so if
you're using docker compose you can run
a docker compose step spin up services
in the background like databases run
tests against that all during your CI
process it has support for things like
terraform and cube CTL and then you can
run arbitrary scripts as well so if you
have existing tests that are shell
scripts or Python scripts that you want
to run you can just simply wrap those up
in a docker file and and run that as
well so just to wrap up before I hand it
off so why cloud build I think first and
foremost it's serverless it handles a
lot of the boring stuff for you it
scales up and down you pay for what you
use and it's isolated so every build
step runs inside of a container and
every build runs inside of a via so VM
is sort of your isolation boundary and
it's ephemeral so we have workers ready
to go to run your jobs and at the end of
a build we'll spin down the VM so
anything that you might have spun up
during the time sort of goes away you
don't really have to worry about
managing state through persistent
environments things like that and the
last is the flexibility so we give you a
lot of the auto box tools that are sort
of the most common use cases but with
things like tests you know a lot of
teams have their own processes have
their own you know tooling that they
wrote around this and really cloud build
allows you to run anything that that
more or less you could you could run and
so with that and it is sort of handed
back to Dave to show us this in action a
little bit more thank Christopher all
right so let's take a look at how we can
use cloud build to actually do some of
this cool integration testing stuff so
I'm gonna show you a demo that includes
this sample application it's a pretty
simple kind of a simplistic version of a
microt service application just two
tiers we've got a web app that's running
nodejs
and a DB that's my sequel but of course
as engineers we know that the only
numbers are 0 1 and infinity which means
this has an infinite number of
micro-services you can definitely scale
up
techniques and this just renders a cloud
cookie shop app and runs inside
kubernetes you can use these techniques
for any kind of integration testing but
here we're focused on a micro service
app with the deploy target kubernetes
integration test flow first we're gonna
build our containers we have the web and
the DB then we're going to provision a
test environment deploy the web and the
DB containers to it so now we have a
system under test there and we're gonna
run a test against it and so again this
isn't an e to e test this is just a
point in time test but it does exercise
both of the layers of the application
it's just gonna curl the endpoint and
grep for a particular string this is a
cookie shop so what its grepping for is
the words chocolate chip that's a
success you know clearly if it passes
then we're good we don't need that that
environment in water will do provision
it and if it doesn't pass the test is
going to end and fail there so most the
time then the environments gonna stay
around so we can debug it though there's
some trade-offs there that I'm going to
show you now in my experience the hard
part of all this is the provisioning
there are a lot of different ways to do
it a lot of trade-offs among the
different ways to do it so we're gonna
look at different mechanisms different
techniques for provisioning and
de-provisioning a system under test so
the first one we're gonna look at is
docker compose now dr. compose is
basically a wrapper around docker if
you've ever run a docker container with
a dash D you're creating a service that
sticks around right docker composed will
spin up multiples of those and let them
Internet work in between each other and
in cloud build the way this happens is
that when you run docker compose within
cloud build and you can there's a
supported builder for docker compose
that lets you clone that and run that in
your project and so what the way that
works is that the builder instantiates
these containers that you're creating
this composed network as sister
containers they share the same network
as it will build steps of your build so
you can interconnect between them and
that's exposed on a network a docker
network called with the cloud build
network and then other steps can talk to
them so here's the flow we start from
our check out from git
the gray box here represents the
boundary of cloud bill that's that
security boundary the Christian we're
talking about where nothing can get in
or out without you expressly doing it
and it's actually only and so the steps
here we're gonna build run some unit
tests and then we use docker composed to
create those sister containers and then
we have our integration test which is
just a shell script asking whether it
succeeded or not and our build is over
so the pros of this is that it's fully
ephemeral everything took place inside
that cloud build environment and when
the test is over everything gets torn
down you don't pay for anything after
the test is over so there's no chance
that you're gonna orphan those resources
and be paying that further after a long
time and for that reason it's
cost-effective there's you're only
paying for that backlog build run which
is build by the minute and is there's
also a free tier generous free tier so
you can get a lot of mileage out of this
now the cons are it's always ephemeral
you can't get back in afterwards and go
poke around inside the docker compose
environment I've done things where I
write a bunch of logs somewhere and it
kind of works but you're still a lot of
spelunking to go and figure out what
happened in there so that's not
necessarily ideal limited fidelity
because we're not gonna use docker
compose as our actual production runtime
it's generally not gonna be your best
choice for that and so therefore it's
not exactly the same behaviour you don't
know if what works here is really gonna
work on prod there are some funny things
about startup order with docker compose
when you start up the containers they
all just start and if they fail to start
they all just fail and so what and I was
working on this I had the web app would
start up faster than the DB the way I
couldn't find the DB and it failed I had
to do some kind of funky workaround to
make it so that it would hang around
until the database came up and in fact
docker compose used to have support for
health checks and removed those
deliberately because it's not designed
to be a production runtime and finally
the one that I liked the least here is
the multiple configs you can't use the
same config for a docker compose
environment as for your production
kubernetes environment and there's
inevitably eager
have drift between those so let's try
again method two so in this case we're
gonna use a gke staging cluster and
deploy all of our our tests to that same
cluster so that sounds like a lot of
things stomping on each other but we're
gonna isolate via namespaces if you're
not familiar a namespace in kubernetes
is a it's an exhalation mechanism where
you scope a number of resources to a
defined namespace now things phases can
talk to each other but you have to do
that deliberately so by default
everything in a namespace thinks that
it's in its own bubble and unless you
work hard to undo this they're gonna be
isolated together in cloud build the way
we're gonna do that is on each build
we're gonna create a uniquely named
namespace deploy those things test it
and then unsuccess will destroy that
namespace a nice thing about namespace
if you destroy the namespace everything
in it wipes away along with it
so in this case what you'll see here is
that we do our build our unit tests and
then we're going to use coop cuddle to
deploy a namespace into our standing
staging cluster and you see that's
outside of the cloud build network and
therefore has a different level of
ephemerality then we'll run our test if
we get to the end coop cuddle is going
to destroy that namespace and all the
resources in it if we don't get to the
end that last step isn't going to run
which means that namespace is going to
hang around so we can use any tools that
we can operate against the cluster on to
go look into those containers look at
their disks etc so the pros of this
excellent fidelity especially if you're
prod happens to be running on gke and i
hope you've heard some things this week
that have helped you think that maybe
that's a good idea
easy teardown delete the namespace and
everything's gone and we have that
ephemerality that we're looking for that
on success it stays on success it
disappears on failure it hangs around to
go debug cons imperfect isolation now
it's unlikely but it's possible that one
of your tests has run away disk usage or
run away memory messes up another test
that's running at the same time on the
same cluster unlikely but something that
is more likely to be a challenge is that
you
can't test a cluster wide resource so
for example the agonist project which
there's been presentation this week is
the cool framework open source framework
for running mostly player games on
kubernetes the way it works is it
creates custom resource definitions and
custom resource definitions our cluster
wide so they can't test different
versions of a cluster of a CRD all in
one cluster um also if you wanted to
validate something against different
versions of kubernetes for example well
you can't have one cluster that has
multiple versions the other problem is
that you may have orphaned resources
that if you fail a test and you don't
bother going in to look at that
namespace that didn't get deleted it's
just gonna hang around not a huge input
impact you know having a namespace with
no activity is in two major problem but
you probably would want to have some
sort of a cleanup script that runs you
know once a week or something and just
deletes everything that everyone forgot
about so now if we wanted to get
absolute isolation we can try using a
kubernetes cluster for each test and
what we're gonna do here is we're going
to create a cooperage cluster in a VM so
that each test has its own completely
isolated environment its own VM that its
operating in and to do that we're gonna
provision that VM with Terra form and
we're going to install a single node
kubernetes application there are several
of these micro kate's mini cube there's
one called k3s these are all compliance
kubernetes frameworks our kubernetes
servers that run on a single node and in
order to offset some of the ephemerality
issues here we're gonna use a
self-destructing vm so if
self-destructing vm is one that if you
forget about it it won't just hang
around and cost you money forever
instead it's built in with a timer
mechanism and after a certain amount of
time if no one touches it it'll delete
itself if you're interested in making
your own self-destructing VMs it's kind
of fun
check out that bitly link so with this
one it's similar to that gke one except
that's this VM is being provisioned on
the fly and has kubernetes or kubernetes
compliance server in it we're going to
deploy our application to that
kubernetes test it
and at the end we're gonna use terraform
to tear it down and again if it doesn't
tear down automatically because of a
success it instead you can go and play
with it for a while and it has an
expiration date after it could be two
hours two days whatever it'll delete
itself so what's good about this one
well perfect isolation near perfect
fidelity again these these non
kubernetes kubernetes they are actually
certified compliant as being kubernetes
runtimes but who knows maybe they're not
exactly the same thing you can test
those cluster level resources and you've
got that ephemerality that we wanted
downside is it still not exactly GTE and
also there's the possibility that these
VMs hang around longer than you want
even if they have an expiration all
right finally when I was working on this
stuff people kept at people like
Christopher kept asking me well why not
just create a GK cluster for everyone
and I said boy that sounds really
expensive and slow but of course it's
possible and by doing that you of course
get all the fidelity all the isolation
you can create the entire production
environment you could even if you wanted
to clone in a database or other things
from production so every single test has
its own gke and it can be done where's
API for and I'm actually going to show
you as part of the test how that works
so let's check on that demo yeah here we
go so what I did when I kicked off that
build back in my IDE is I ran what I
call a meta CI this is a cloud build
invocation that kicks off other cloud
building vacations and each one of those
is one of these testing mechanisms in
every case we're testing the exact same
application running the exact same test
script on it but we're instantiating and
tearing down our test environments in
different ways so we have all four of
the messages I just showed you and if we
look into the UI we'll see that they all
completed and they all returned the same
result but very different amounts of
time the docker composed was very quick
because it didn't have to reach to any
external resources but gke cluster
protests pretty slow but perfect
fidelity and the other ones are
somewhere in between
so what's the right choice for something
that you're gonna do it really depends
on what you're doing we switch back to
the slides please so in summary we took
a look at a number of different
mechanisms for spinning up and testing
against a micro service production
environment and you can see they all
have pros and cons for example with
docker compose it scales really big you
don't have any extra resources that
shared staging kubernetes is pretty good
all around but that's a perfect
isolation a kubernetes per test should
scale but at some point you're probably
gonna hit some quota limits on IPS and
think I haven't tried running you know
tens of thousands of those though you'll
probably would be kind of fun all in all
when I was working on this book trust me
what's the right one I said oh it all
depends it doesn't matter matters what
you're doing but really on balance for
most use cases I think this is a really
good choice the shared kubernetes
environment if you turn on auto scaling
it's gonna scale up and scale down to
meet the needs of your developers so
you're not gonna have standing resources
beyond you know a minimum number of
nodes over the weekend you've got all of
that great fidelity its vast and the
isolation is probably good enough for
most workloads if it's not quite there
maybe you add one of those more intense
things as a final check we can do more
we can use these same kind of methods to
do deeper end-to-end tests in a scripted
testing creates an order put something
in a shopping cart buy some cookies we
could do mobile web testing do we
there's a service called firebase test
labs that Google provides to test
against Android devices in iOS and we
can use external resources so say for
example we wanted to spin up a dedicated
cloud sequel for test we could do that
so this application and all of these
test methods are available on github I
encourage you to download it give it a
try pull requests are welcome feedback
is welcome speaking of feedback wait
I'll get to that in a second
speaking of feedback tweet at me here's
my Twitter I would love to hear from you
what you're up to how you're approaching
problems like this Christopher doesn't
really do Twitter so if you want to get
a personalized response for him just go
to cloud build and go to that feedback
link and who
right back to it's like a stationery
calligraphy it's great I kid but we it
is actually a really responsive team and
they absolutely want to hear your
feedback and they're absolutely
listening
[Music]